Neil and I were given a huge lamp of
metallic utopium and so we felt it was
time to update our video about utopium
you will have seen Brady and Pete going
to Italy where the elements or the
minerals containing a terbium were first
discovered
so
look at the Honda
to the left oh wow so Neil and I felt
that this lamp of etobium Justified
making a new video
that we were not terribly hopeful that
it would be very exciting and we were
totally surprised
it was fantastic really nice Sparks and
colors and some quite nice thoughts as
well like it so let's begin
the mineral that eterbium was discovered
in was found in Sweden but it was
actually isolated in Switzerland in
Geneva
by the Swiss chemist jeans
quite a fancy name easy for you to say
yeah and when he died there was a
memorial lecture in his honor by The
Chemical Society the Forerunner of the
Royal Society of chemistry honoring this
really famous chemist it has a nice
picture of him as well but I found it
really quite fascinating because it
described his lab the laboratory in
which he's so zealously labeled for
upwards of 30 years and which was the
birthplace of his most important
investigations is described as a damp
and gloomy Cellar more like the den of
an alchemist than the workroom of a
modern chemist here he worked alone
without assistance nowadays professors
have whole teams of students and other
researchers he was doing it all himself
he was analyzing an oxide from one of
the elements in this mineral called
gadolinite this was really painstaking
work heating things up dissolving them
up again then trying to isolate
different compounds and he found an
extra oxide that he was not expecting in
what was meant to be a Pure Element or
pure oxide of an element and he
published the paper he was from Geneva
so it was in French which was called
which means about
eterbium a new element or Earth
contained in gadolinate which is the
mineral that came from Italy this is a
paper discovering a new element and it's
four pages long the really key point was
that he measured the atomic weight or
trying to estimate the atomic weight of
the element He had just a tiny amount of
this oxide that he got and he worked out
that and I won't read it in French I
will just translate it the atomic weight
of eterbium and he chose the name
metopium because it came from Italy was
either 115 or
172.5 depending on whether the formula
of the oxide was ybo or yb203 turns out
that it is yb203 and his value of 172.5
is close to the modern value of 173
which I think is amazing here he is in
the dark damp cellar producing results
that are pretty close to the modern
values so I'll tell you a bit more about
the marinyak but let's get back to the
chemistry and our lamp of the turbium
before we look at the metal itself it's
worth looking at one of the salts and we
were given a sample of yerbium chloride
and Neil has a nice set of reagent
bottles with Solutions of different
salts and so we started putting some of
the etobium chloride into these salts
we began with potassium carbonate
and there was a nice white precipitate
almost certainly
etobium carbonate
then came potassium chromate which is
yellow and there was a really nice
precipitate of yellow
eterbium chromate I'd really quite
expected that because most chromates are
insoluble we then tried sodium sulfide
which didn't produce any precipitate at
all
Brady thought was quite excited
Professor was wrong we got nice
precipitates with potassium hydroxide
and ammonium hydroxide
though kneel
sniffed the ammonium hydroxide to check
it was okay
and I don't think he'll be getting a
cold for some time
ammonium hydroxide
is that still okay
oh
yeah yes
the final one which Neil thought would
work was potassium iodide
I said it wouldn't and now the one that
Martin guarantees is going to be
disappointing
steak is a professional career on this
one
and nothing happened
so
Brady felt the day was justified in
being a professor you get to keep your
professorship
we like the potassium carbonate and
dichromate so much
that we decided to do them again a
little more precisely with Neil dropping
in the etobium chloride
drop by drop so that you could watch the
precipitate forming in a more artistic
manner the chemistry is the same but the
mixing is slower so the reaction takes
longer we then went to a lump of metal
we were given this lump of metal by our
friend Anthony lipmann whose company
buys and sells metals and I think this
was a sample from which people had
drilled out little bits and bits off so
it had all sorts of quite interesting
markings so it was almost like a work of
art in its own right but a lamp of metal
isn't really very useful for doing
chemistry with
so poor Neal had to file off the metal
to get some powder and the first thing
we tried to do was to dissolve the
powder in hot water
it is claimed the disturbium will
dissolve in hot water to give the
hydroxide and hydrogen so Neil heated it
up there was a little bit of hydrogen
perhaps I persuaded Neil to Jazz it up
with some hydrochloric acid
hydrogen now
unfortunately the test for hydrogen
didn't work it almost looked as if Neil
was extinguishing a splint with hydrogen
but I don't think that was what was
actually happening so what was really
exciting was Neil dropping the powdered
utopium into the flame of a Bunsen
burner
there were fireworks
everywhere bright Sparks and I was quite
interested because at the end of the
Sparks as they were flying outwards it
seemed to be orange but I think that
might be red hot particles of the
material because they flew away
and there was a slight greenish tinge
but the amount of light was really
impressive
almost washed out the image from Brady's
camera
and then I'd read that if you mix the
terbium with poly
tetrafluoroethylene PTFE you can get a
bright emerald green color so two days
ago I bought a packet of powdered PTFE
online it arrived just in time Neil
makes some of this white powder together
with his filings viterbium
and dropped it into the Bunsen Flame
and indeed you did get a much brighter
green color
[Music]
I think it's greener
I think that the green color must be due
to some
form of iterbium fluoride in a highly
excited state but exactly what it is I
have no idea perhaps some of you the
viewers know exactly what it is but it
was really exciting let's go back to the
marinyak and the thing that's
interesting that he isolated the oxide
he never actually isolated the element
and most surprisingly metallic utterbium
like we've got was first isolated in
so we're just about the 70th anniversary
of the isolation of metallic utterbium
so unfortunately Paul the martinac never
saw these wonderful colors from Bunsen
burners that we did nevertheless I think
it's really important to stress that
discoveries of these elements are really
quite an international effort
the mineral was discovered in Sweden it
was transported to Geneva where the
element was discovered by a Swiss
chemist and his Discovery was recognized
by all sorts of honors including the
Davy medal of the Royal Society of
London
so he was recognized very well for his
achievements
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]